Hey youtubers it's Charlie and since Marvel
just confirmed Josh Brolin as the voice of
Thanos in Guardians and Avengers 2 I wanted
to do a breakdown of what that might look
like. The Avengers 2 news is a little bit
surprising given Ultron is the real villain
of that movie. I'll also include some Ant-Man
news since Edgar Wright left the project.
There be chaos in the Marvel Universe this
week.
If you're finding me for the first time I
do Marvel and DC videos every week. Be sure
to subscribe to get everything. Guardians
is the next movie but I try to rotate the
bonus videos I do, feel free to leave me suggestions
for topics.
So let's talk about Thanos first, then Guardians,
then Avengers and then Ant Man. In case you
have no idea who Thanos is he's currently
the biggest villain in the Marvel Universe.
You probably saw him during the post-credits
scene of the first Avengers movie. He was
the one who gave Loki his staff and he was
also controlling the Chitauri. The reason
why Marvel hasn't mentioned him in any of
the movies by name yet is just because he's
a cosmic villain. And we're just now getting
to Guardians of The Galaxy. Think of it as
Marvel's progression of evil. You start out
with Loki and Malekith, then move up to The
Collector and finally to the boss of bosses,
Thanos.
Technically there are more powerful beings
in the comics, like the cosmic entity Death,
who is a big part of Thanos and the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline. But I don't think the
movies are going to invoke her. So for now,
Thanos is the top of the food chain. He's
the apex predator like Godzilla.
Based on what Marvel is saying, he'll have
minor roles in both Guardians of The Galaxy
and Avengers 2. Those films have really big
casts already, so I'm not expecting Thanos
to steal the limelight away from Benicio Del
Toro or James Spader as Ultron. But because
Avengers 3 is supposed to culminate this whole
Infinity Gems plotline, they can't wait all
the way till 2018 or whenever that movie comes
out to introduce him officially.
The story about his first appearance in the
comics is kind of funny, because it ties in
with all the changes they're making to Ultron's
origin in Avengers 2. Thanos premiered in
1973 as part of this story that went across
several different comic books. The first one
was Iron Man, Iron Man #55 to be specific.
Just to explain my ultron reference in case
you didn't know. Ultron is going to evolve
from Stark Tech owned by the Military. Remember
how he's 'privatizing' world security. That
involves developing AI systems like JARVIS
for the military.
So now it makes more sense why they would
want to include Thanos in Avengers 2. They
would have done it in a post-credit scene
anyway, but now it sounds like he'll get a
longer scene that's part of the story itself.
But let's not get off track, He's in Guardians
of the Galaxy. Let's talk about what that's
probably going to look like.
So we've seen the main cast, minus the big
guy. We don't officially know what the macguffin
of the movie is. Whether it's one of the infinity
gems or some other object tied to the gauntlet,
but the story they teased, Ronan and the Accuser
Corps attacking a planet and the Guardians
trying to save it. That's all surface level
story. The gems and the guantlet is what's
hiding underneath it all.
Think about it this way. A big army attacks
a planet for a reason. What's the obvious
reason and what's the secret reason. Who's
pulling Ronan the Accuser's Strings? Probably
The Collector, Benicio Del Toro. He seems
like a neutral figure even though he's dressed
like Space Liberace. Take it a step further.
Who's pulling his strings? Probably Thanos.
At the end of Thor The Dark World the Warriors
Three gave the Collector the Aether. That's
basically one of the infinity gems. If you're
a comic book reader who's confused by them
substituting that weird Red Energy for a physical
Gem, just remember the speech Odin gave at
the beginning of Dark World. He was telling
the story of the Infinity Gems. He called
them Relics that pre-date the creation of
the Universe. He went on to say that some
of them exist in different forms. Some as
stones, as in gems. And some exist like the
Aether.
My guess is that in Guardians of the Galaxy,
that round artifact Star Lord is trying to
steal is one of the gems. Quick side note
too. It hasn't been confirmed, but I think
that the mind gem was what was powering Loki's
staff. The one that Baron Von Strucker was
experimenting on at the end of Winter Soldier.
That's where Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch's
powers are going to come from. Yeah I know,
changing more backstories.
So what is Thanos going to be doing at the
end of Guardians? I'm guessing he's just going
to be taking the gems The Collector has, or
just communicating with him for mission updates.
Every Time I've seen Thanos in the comics
he's always acted through henchmen and servants.
He does punch the shit out of Hulk during
Marvel's Infinity Event last year, but generally
he doesn't dirty his hands unless one of them
is wearing a gem encrusted glove. That just
happens to control all of reality.
There was this comic book story called Thanos
Imperative where he actually worked with the
Guardians to stop the Universe from being
destroyed, so over the years he's become this
really interesting complex character. But
because he's such a powerful person, you can't
just roll him out for every single story.
That being said, I think Hell just be straight
up bad guy from the Guardians movie and all
the way to Avengers 3. Beyond that it just
depends on what ever ends up happening during
that movie.
Avengers 2 as it applies to Thanos is a bit
trickier. It's called Age of Ultron, but really
it should be called the rise of Ultron. Thanos
isn't directly related to that, so I'm interested
to see how they bring him into the story without
overshadowing Ultron.
They're changing a lot of origin stories in
the movie, Ultron's origins and Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch's origins. We know a couple
things. Loki's staff, tesseract energy or
the mind gem. However you want to think about
it. Is where Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch's
powers come from. Very different from the
comics, I know.
Baron Von Strucker talked about the Age of
Miracles, as if the cosmic energy from the
staff were helping to give birth to a new
age. See where I'm going with this?
I think that Ultron is going to evolve from
a combination of AI Stark Tech like JARVIS
interacting with the same type of energy that
gave Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch their powers.
Hail Hydra.
Seriously though, HYDRA is on the run, Baron
Von Strucker's secret research team is like
a HYDRA inside of HYDRA. They're the one's
behind all this. So I think he'll be directly
involved with the creation of Ultron. Like
he and Tony Stark are going to accidentally
give birth to a deeply disturbed mechanical
baby.
Since the tesseract and energy from the mind
gem are involved. I think Thanos will really
only show up to collect those things. He probably
won't care about anything going on between
Ultron and the Avengers. They did beat the
Chitauri army, but they're still flies on
his radar at this point.
I'm really interested to see if anything happens
during Guardians of The Galaxy or Avengers
2 to change that. Because it's implied that
by Avengers 3, the Avengers will meet Thanos
directly in combat.
Now it's your turn though. What do you think
about Josh Brolin being the voice of Thanos.
If James Spader can do a crazy awesome Ultron,
I think James Brolin can pull off Thanos'
deep gravely voice.
So because this came along really quick I'm
just pushing my Maleficent Review to tomorrow
morning be sure to subscribe to get it. Then
Orphan Black Saturday night and Fire and Blood
all of Sunday.
Right now click here for my Breakdown of the
Guardians of The Galaxy Trailer and Click
here to learn more about Avengers 2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!